in the first 10 to 15 seconds of the
earthquake the dozens of apartment
buildings here collapsed those inside
had no chance
they were built before 1999.
but here everyone survived they were
built after 1999.
that was when an earlier quake in Turkey
prompted a strengthening of building
regulations
Eunice kachma is a local architect says
98 of the buildings that collapsed in
caravan marash were built before the new
standards were introduced
it hurts to see all this destruction but
I'm angry too this could easily have
been avoided I've lost family members
everyone's affected by this it's been
proven once again that what matters is
science mathematics will never fail you
even with such a massive earthquake only
two percent of the new buildings
collapsed Eunice's low-rise office is
the style of building he says he wanted
to see built here it's more integrated
into the Earth he says so more able to
withstand shaking and swaying three
years ago Eunice and his colleagues held
a meeting with officials to warn of the
dangers of an earthquake the Chamber of
Architects urged the local Council to
evacuate all this area demolish and
rebuild again to new standards but it
would have meant uprooting thousands and
thousands of people and hundreds of
businesses
it was never done
then there were tens of thousands of
amnesties given by the government to
people who built newer structures that
failed to meet the latest standards
instead a fine was paid which just in
2018 earned the ministry of environment
more than four billion dollars
immense pain here Jamil USDA shimichi
says he's a building auditor so many
variables can affect the strength of a
construction he says right down to how a
trainee Builder mixes the concrete
there's no one reason why a building
collapses it could have been the type of
soil A Fault In the construction plan or
the engineering the workmanship or
something external we have many
buildings badly damaged by other falling
buildings there need to be technical
inspections and only then can we take
the steps necessary for a safe future
turkey as President erdogan says he
wants the First new homes to be ready
within a year The Architects in this
town want them to be built to survive
the next quake
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera karamamarash